welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the man the myth
the mephisto
and this video we're breaking down
episode four of falcon in the winter
soldier
after a thrilling season we're getting
all of the pieces falling into place
and there's a lot of plot theories
easter eggs and things you missed that
we're going to be talking about
before that though i just want to point
out an easter egg that i got sent by
logancali13 on instagram
who noticed that in the museum in
episode 1 we see a photo of steve
holding a taxi door with a star on it
this is of course from captain america
the first avenger and if we jump back to
that movie we can actually see the
person that took this photo
standing in the crowd showing that it's
all connected
it's all connected now last week we saw
sam and bucky freeing zemo
in order to track down the origins of
the brand new and improved super soldier
serum
and this led them to madrapur after
learning it was the power broker all
along
they were reunited with sharon carter
who seem more suspicious than tom
holland when he's trying to keep a
secret
we also got a small clip of zemo busting
out dance moves
that would make star-lord and justin
hammer evacuate the dance floor
earlier in the week the actor behind him
daniel bruhl revealed that he actually
did a longer dance but that marvel cut
it down
and after fans united together and got
hashtag released the zemo cut trending
they dropped an hour-long version of it
last night i sat through the entire
thing
75 times i don't give a [ __ ]
now there was also a sign on the embassy
that a lot of people commented saying
was a nod to the x-men
and actually drove around throughout the
week looking for this on the road
it's actually used quite a lot over here
and i got the wife to take a photo of it
and as you can see it clearly confirms
that the x-men exist
in the heavy spoilers universe it's all
connected
now we ended with a big cliffhanger and
saw that ao had been sent from wakanda
to bring zemo in
before you could say what kind of [ __ ]
is this we cut to black
panther's music and then the credits now
episode 4 starts off with a flashback to
wakanda
where we see io initiating the
brainwashing words on bucky to see if he
can retain control of himself
during this we cut to flashes of both
civil war and captain america the winter
soldier
to see the times when these words were
used on him in order to hurt people
there's flashes of the stark's death and
his many attacks in the winter soldier
and we get the feeling that he's haunted
by
all of it over the top of these moments
we can also hear the winter soldier
theme tune
but alongside the clips of him snapping
out of it this music changes to subtly
hint to us that he's finally free
you can really see that he has an
attachment to ao who
in many ways breaks him out of his
enslavement now i love how we go from
this statement of her saying that he's
now free
to her asking how could you free him in
regards to zemo
shuri is name dropped as is king tachaka
and you really get the feeling of
betrayal that the wakandans feel
after all they did help bucky and he's
now sided with the murderer that killed
their king
after giving him a deadline of eight
hours ao leaves bucky to return to
zemo's place in latvia
now i forgot to mention last week that
in the marvel universe this is actually
a neighboring country to liberia
aka the home of viktor von doom whether
he pops up or not remains to be seen
but it is an interesting location to
choose the trio learned of carly's
attack last week
and zemo goes off on a monologue about
how the idea of the super soldier
always leads to supremacy this is
actually very similar to something that
flagsmash has said in sam wilson captain
america
and during a run-in with the lmd version
of him in the comics
he discussed nationalism black smashes
said that believing one's country is
supreme
means that you believe others who are
part of the other within it
do not deserve the same rights he
proposed that nationalism
always leads to fascism and this was
something that was prominent in germany
during the second world war
they believed that the aryan was the
supreme race and even referred to them
as being the superman characteristics of
the aryan
included blonde hair and blue eyes which
are things that both steve rogers and
john walker possess
juxtaposing this the flag smashes are
made up of people who don't possess
these characteristics
and thus they're in direct opposition
this too has led to them going off on
their own path of radicalization
and with both opposing sides leading to
wanting their way
it means that we're destined for war
whereas john walker operates with the
help of the government
the flag smashers do not and we join
them out in the wilderness
turns out that after the attack the grc
has put in place something known as the
patch act
which will create stricter borders in
episode 1 we discover that the flag
smashers wanted open ones
so this is very much against their goals
and it's all carly's fault stricter
borders leads to an empowered police
force
and i very much get the feeling of
escalation throughout this entry as we
watch
each side participating in more and more
violent acts in order to beat the other
sam bucky and zemo arrive at the flag
smasher base and the former quickly
realizes that it's their place of
operation
due to the red hand print this is
actually based on the hamza
which we see carly holding in this
episode now the hamza is meant to bring
its own a look
happiness health and good fortune
however it also acts as a defense
against the evil eye eyes have appeared
in the season at several points
namely episode 3 when we saw a sign of
mad report which said the power broker
is watching
this is a play on the phrase big brother
is watching you and with the hamza
inclusion as part of the flag smasher
logo
it certainly lets us know that the two
sides are in opposition to one another
the episode itself is called the whole
world is watching and this very much
sets up the ending which we'll talk
about later on now the refugees
displaced here
felt let down by the grc and it's clear
that after the snap six months ago
their priorities changed as we theorized
the population being downsized due to
the snap
would have led to more opportunities in
work travel and progression
for example say all of middle management
in a company got snapped
then the people at the bottom would be
able to ascend faster and take their
jobs
leading to them gaining a better quality
of life but when they return they'd
likely have to vacate these positions
or at least fight for them and it's led
to people feeling
well completely let down now these
people have united behind carly
and though she may be going about it the
wrong way it's clear she wants to help
people other than herself
after learning of donya's funeral and
not telling sam and bucky
i also have to ask them don't you wish
you didn't trust zemo so much i haven't
thought now this causes bucky to lose it
but he calms down and zemo asks if he
wants some cherry blossom tea
this could be a reference to cherry
blossom who just so happened to work for
an
organization known as the hand now
speaking of hands
mine is actually hurting right now
because that's the biggest reach i've
ever done no
cut to shady sharon and we see that she
has several goons on her side
a lot of people have theorized that
sharon is the power broker
but personally i don't believe it as
zemo said that he did know the villain
before he was jailed
which was during the time that she was
operating as agent 13.
however she does seem to have
connections to him and is able to lend a
satellite to sam for surveillance
showing how high up she is now the
antagonist is furious
after nagel was killed because he was
the golden goose
and we cut to carly who still has the
super soldier serum he's after
this gravestone belongs to one of the
members grandfathers
who we learn was a world war ii
resistance fighter he clearly instilled
in his grandson a positive image of
captain america
and we very much get the idea that carly
could become the next one because of her
beliefs and values
he states that captain america should
look like and represent the people that
are forgotten
however she says the shield is a relic
of a bygone era
and wants to destroy it now this is
something that sam reiterated last time
subtly hinting to us that he too
possesses the values that are needed
right now
and letting us know that he is worthy in
latvia
walker and battle star track down the
trio and before he loses his temper
wilson tells him to stop being so weird
just stop being weird mate
i love why it's betrayal in this show
and you really feel a guy could lose it
at any second
he's very homeland in my opinion and i'm
on the edge almost every time he's on
screen
sadly wyatt russell has been receiving
death threats over the last week
i just have to say to everyone now yeah
hate the character
don't hate the actor anyway walker gives
them 10 minutes to apprehend carly at
the funeral
and this adds another time limit to a
show that's already full of time limits
carly gives a speech which distills her
beliefs and this echoes sharon's at
peggy's funeral
clearly donya was another maternal
figure that everyone has respect for
and this makes carly a really complex
anti-hero
which allows us to see why she's viewed
as a robin hood figure
now outside walker starts to get
impatient and though we believe that he
already had the super soldier serum
within it
it is revealed that he didn't this is in
opposition to the comics
and the entire power broker plot line
from the source material
now i think it's safe to say that the
power broker is slowly becoming the big
bad of the series
and though us agent is gonna be somewhat
of an antagonist too
the former is the palpatine of this show
the mantle has been taken up by several
characters
and originally the villain was a
businessman known as curtis jackson
not him now his goal was to run a
criminal organization
as if it was a respectable business and
after meeting with dr colemailis the
pair formed a company called power
broker incorporated
malice appeared in sam wilson captain
america which this show also heavily
pulls from
it looks like they're bringing together
multiple arcs and runs in order to tell
this adaptation
power broker inc ended up selling
superhuman abilities to clients
and they were behind empowering us agent
demolition man
no not that one and several members of
the ucwf
in the comics jackson used the
procedures on himself and in doing so he
grew muscles to the point that he was
actually unable to move
jackson later became confined to a
mechanical suit but was still heavily
hampered by his newfound augmentations
more recently another character has
taken up the mantle and this power
broker wears a battle suit that allows
him to fire energy blasts from his hands
but can he fire up the dance floor with
his hands absolutely not
so they are going against that by the
looks of it and having walker completely
disconnected from him
we discovered that kali and ko were
actually ousted from their positions as
soon as people returned
and it speaks to how the grc only wanted
them when they provided use
i actually loved seeing sam and carly
talking it out
and though this episode up until this
point had been slower paced in terms of
action
it did paint out people's political
beliefs and ideologies
though carly doesn't believe she's a
supremacist she does state later on that
she believed she'd been
chosen which is something throughout
history that many supremacists have said
no one believes they are the bad guys
and sam actually agrees with carly on
several levels
he just can't co-sign how she's acting
walker arrives and messes things up
and zemo escapes after undoing his
handcuffs he of course wants to wipe out
super soldiers across the world
because he believes it leads to
supremacy and he gets the jump on kali
zemo destroys the super soldier serum
remnants and walker takes the last vial
leading to him using on himself clearly
the pressure got too much for him
and this led to him believing that he
needed to take it in order to keep up
with things
that very much ties back to the theme of
escalation which we've seen throughout
this episode at several points
now there is a parallel conversation in
the entry in which both sam and walker
discuss
whether they would take the super
soldier serum or not sam states he
wouldn't
and he does so definitively however
walker convinces himself that it's
the right thing to do even though we
know so far it's created nothing but
misery
this is true to the comics as he of
course ended up with it
whereas sam never took it even when he
was captain america
walker feels completely inadequate and
due to his past
namely the hypocrisy that comes with war
he decides that it's right to take it
as erskine said the serum enhances
what's already there
and thus taking it if you're bad will
make you super bad
walker shows up and wants to go toe to
toe with sam
showing how oppressive he is and that
unlike the latter
he will never talk it out with anyone
they're saved from going at it by the
dora melanche who kicked the crap out of
john and battlestar
further driving home why he feels the
need to take the serum
they leave bucky looking pretty armless
and zemo makes off
by pulling in el chapo this is a
reference to the real-life drug lord who
had tunnels built under his home
that he used to escape from the
authorities with now where he's gone
exactly we don't know
but in the trailers we do see him at the
sokovian memorial
so i'm guessing that he's now at this
location he did mention it in episode
three to sam and bucky
so that would give him a clue that he
was there carly reaches out to sarah
and gets her to send a message to sam
which includes threatening her
that we do see her struggling with sam
and bucky then meet up with her
and she asks them to join forces but
they turn it down
and thus this sets them on a collision
course she states she doesn't want to
kill sam
and we watch across town as walker and
battle star enter the flag smasher
hideout
this moment heavily echoes the scene
from the first avenger
in which steve bust into a hideout with
guns drawn
now one thing i also noticed here is
that the american flag appears in black
and white on walker's uniform
according to google the flag being
portrayed in this fashion
is to show solidarity with the police
and it cements that walker is very much
a metaphor for them
it could also showcase the black and
white way that he views the world
and that he's missing the shades of grey
that are required to take into account
all perspectives
now at the location we haven't confirmed
that walker did take the serum
and there's somewhat of a staircase
fight which echoes the iconography of
civil war
with the serum in his veins walker is
finally able to go toe-to-toe with the
flag smashes
and we also see bucky busting out some
of the knife skills that he had in the
winter soldier
what's funny about this is that in the
first avenger howard stark told steve
that he needed a shield
because hydra wouldn't be coming at them
with pocket knives
bucky of course ended up working for
hydra and coming at steve with a
pocketknife
which marries these moments across the
mcu
carly goes to kill walker but this leads
to more deaths when lamar jumps in the
way
and gets killed with a super soldier
punch having his best friend die like
this sends walker off the deep end
and this further leads to escalation
this eye for an eye mentality
always leads to both people losing their
sight and though i don't mean they lose
their sight
walker does kill one of the flag smasher
forces
in order to avenge battle star walker
jumps out a window in a moment that's
similar to steve jumping through one in
civil war
and outside he murders a down man for
all to see
now clearly this is a metaphor for
police brutality
and how innocent and unarmed people are
often killed which is then captured on
camera
this leads to social media outcry and
acts like this often split the discord
into left and right politically
with both sides arguing over the rights
and wrongs of doing it
though a lot of people think that this
is the end for walker
uh i actually don't think it will be
don't know why i went ah
there but we'll keep that in the edit
now because he's working within the law
i think that things will be brushed
under the rug and there will be constant
pr to spin it that he acted in the right
way
we see this a lot in real life and
walker could end up metaphorically
showcasing that
even if you're caught in 4k if you're
working for a certain side you have far
more power
the danger he poses is that he's now no
longer working within the law
and he believes he is the law which
speaks to why the character
is beyond repair at this point the
shield has a long legacy
and to end with it covered in blood
symbolizes how far this symbol has come
from being something that stood for
defense to now something that stands for
oppression
it's a chilling way to end the entry and
it's probably the best ending to any of
the episodes in the series so far
okay and before we get into the review
part of the video i just want to thank
you for all supporting the channel
throughout the last four weeks
if you've enjoyed the video then i'd
appreciate the thumbs up and click the
subscribe button if you want to keep up
to date with our other crap breakdowns
don't click it if you've already
subscribed yeah that's not how it works
your bloody dingus
now as for the show itself though i'm
still really enjoying it
i don't know if it's quite capturing my
interest in the same way that one
division did
though i'm hyped as hell whenever i
finish an episode and can't wait to
watch the next one
by the time monday rolls around i notice
that me and the boys have stopped
talking about it
the whole crew used to love paying
theories back and forth with me about
one division each and every day
whereas here it's a bit straightforward
even with some of the big twists and
cliffhangers
now that's not to say it's bad at all
and i think even if you compare the
first four episodes of this to the first
four of one division
and falcon in the winter soldier is a
lot better in my opinion anyway
and that might be unfair as they have a
longer run time but even if compared to
say the first
six i would still say these are an
improvement however they are slightly by
the numbers whereas
with one division you didn't really know
what you were gonna get
so as far as keeping people's interests
i think that that show was a lot more
successful than this
it may be an unfair comparison but with
them both being marvel disney plus shows
i feel that it's fair however
as much as i sound like i'm slagging it
off i'm not
i really really really enjoy the show
and i just wanted to talk about more of
my general feelings as the series has
gone on
i think you would really struggle to
ding this and though i know there's
people out there that don't always like
the political and social commentary
i do feel like it's important for marvel
to tackle these issues
captain america first hit the mainstream
hitting hitler
and since then the comics have tackled
themes like race
civil rights steroid abuse the patriot
act and a lot more
therefore it feels fitting to me
especially in today's climate that a
show based around what it means to be
captain america
would be tackling things like this as
for the episode itself
again i really enjoyed it and this is
such a solid show that it's difficult to
ding any of its acting
action or the production quality that it
delivers it's a worldwide
globetrotting adventure that i feel is a
satisfying side step into the more
grounded aspects of the mcu
and i can't wait to see what happens
next now the rumors that there will be a
big cameo
coming in episode 5 have long persisted
and over the last week these have picked
up even more steam
if you missed our last video then in
that we discussed how there was a big
character on set during the filming of
this show
and the appearance is at the old decal
courthouse apparently they filmed for
two days
and it is a moment that will make your
jaw hit the floor the character is
apparently female
and when discussing what's coming down
the line malcolm spellman the show's
creator said the following
there are characters in our series who i
would love to see partnered with like
it's a very very grounded character
partnered with one of the big world
checkers like thor or someone like that
the personality is so strong it's the
episode 5 character
i'd love to see that character with thor
now there's not really a lot to take
from this and my guess
based off the thor comments would be
that it's someone like she hulk
or maybe even rogue i mean we all saw
that road sign didn't we
that road sign confirming that yes the
x-men
are part of the heavy spoilers universe
it could also be florence pugh's
character aka elena baloa
who had the pandemic not hit would be an
established character in the mcu by now
she's gonna be a big part of black widow
i'm being more grounded
i do think that makes a lot of sense
anyway i really hope this isn't a
letdown and that it
is the big moment that we've been
promised i have been let down in the
past
i'm looking at you paul bettany but yeah
hype hype still remains and i still hold
out hope now obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts and theories
as we head into the penultimate entry so
make sure you comment below and let me
know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe the notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the best easter eggs in godzilla vs kong
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over top to bottom on all
the cool callbacks to the monster base
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more
without the way thank you for sending
through the video i've been paul i see
you next time
take care peace